all right guys it is here i will be in
rayleigh raleigh royally
really north carolina i know you're mad
at me for not saying it right good
nights and that's september 23rd through
25th show up buy tickets
tell me how to say it i will learn by
the end of the weekend i'll then be in
denver colorado at the comedy works
october 14th through 16th i'll be at
laugh out loud in san antonio texas the
october 23rd 22nd through 23rd skankfest
in houston that's already sold out uh
plano texas house of comedy november
11th through 14th
and then there's a lot more go to
annieletterman.com to grab tickets and
also uh get some merch
[Music]
i just i literally walked in george was
like here you put this on you're a
little early
so yeah you didn't learn to not be early
no i thought you said 11 i don't know
are you always early yeah
sort of i mean i'm definitely like an on
time person
but not half an hour early i i think i
got the time wrong the half an hour
early is the most intrusive thing for me
no i know it's real social can kill you
it is right i agree i don't like it when
people are early especially you know
when you have like a couple people over
and somebody you're like
shows up like an hour early and you're
like i'm not even beginning to prepare
for your arrival yeah i have to get
ready for you dumb to come to my house
yeah and i have to clear my energy i
have to physically fix it
report is not
fully finished
but also you just i just have so much
social anxiety it's like i thought i had
one more hour of being at peace yeah and
then i was like i'm sorry i was early i
haven't really my post
out i didn't haven't rubbed one off yet
i'm here anxious now i have to go into
the bathroom and put the bidet on so you
guys i don't think i have a whole lot of
blood flow left in my in my vagina what
do you mean you guys have to do are you
a vibrator girl
i know i'm a finger girl that's just
exclusively okay so what happens first
is i stopped growing hair in my pubic
area not on the side
like oh my god are they going to go
inside can i show you my pubic area yeah
i have no hair i want to see what she
does
not from i wish this was the first
meeting not
i'm so jealous i know let me see that
just
wait not from laser or anything yeah
that's wild
the little the few on the side are very
there's yeah they're stragglers but i
didn't look on the side there was just
like one more look
let me get a little sniff too
so how does this happen
there's barely any you could pluck as
many as there are there i have more on
my upper lip than you have on your i
have more in my [ __ ] than i do the
rest of my oh my god you have a mullet
oh
she's got a mullet [ __ ] in the mullet
guys well here's what i'm saying
so oh my god do you think theo is gonna
think that's a secret message oh my god
i'm the rat queen
so i don't think i have a lot of blood
flow also on top of that
i would the sensation is kind of i would
go asian i would go i'm asian no no no
the sensation has lessened
like i'm not feeling like strong like
the same strong
feelings down there i just had a [ __ ]
vision
that you are going to be one of those
people that needs to get like shot in
the ch in a bulletproof vest to feel
how you becoming this people i just need
one of you guys to tase me right in the
morning i think wait you guys i sat next
to a guy on the plane who works for
taser for like the original taser gun
and i was like can i come get tased by
like the main and he was like yeah they
do like tasings wait really yeah they do
like uh like whoever wants to do it
anyone that works on the comp at the
company i think has to have it done
which is kind of hilarious like you have
to like i don't want to i'm just the
secretary like
everyone gets teased yeah
even the custodian
the product to know what the product is
but i would want to and i would like to
i would like to drink as much water as
possible i would like to ensure i'm
going to piss myself do you do people
[ __ ] themselves i think they do i think
they do i think they paid whatever's in
there i think it's just going to
energize someone like annie
yeah it's just gonna be like
cocaine for her yeah yeah
she doesn't go down at all do you do you
feel like there's like i don't know
sometimes i like feel like i feel so
much that like
you stop it you like shut it all down
just that like i don't i pain doesn't
even i don't even like
notice it like my i i sliced my finger
last night and i just kept doing it and
then i was like you have to stop for a
minute
[Laughter]
well both of you how about this i i
taste the both of them i agree yeah
i do have the product here
i have uh
i've never
put batteries in it yet but someone sent
me oh i do have the [ __ ] we should do
the show the shock collar really did
hurt me more than i've ever experienced
like oh the dog yeah but i guess you're
not supposed to the prongs directly on
skin oh actually i have my parents have
this dog named lily she's just like
[ __ ] crazy a crazy [ __ ] she has so
many issues and she has gotten she's so
like dead set on her ways that there's a
they have a shot collar for her and if
she sees like a deer or something she
will run the [ __ ] right through that
shot collar oh she'll go through like
this she's like
yeah and she'd just go after the deer
and you're like dude that's like it's on
the highest setting yeah that's i think
we're like that that's the thirst for
deer for deer blood you did
you look like sweet tooth you're you're
a descendant of deer you're a little
deer wait can i tell did i ever tell you
about when i was at i was with a
therapist like one of my first like like
fun therapist my woo therapist
and um he was like all right close your
eyes you're like in the woods like what
animal do you say and i said a deer and
he's like that's your spirit i'm gonna
go uh i want a [ __ ] redo i'm not
gonna be a goddamn deer i was so pissed
i was like i'm gonna be a wolf or
something oh
i think we underestimate deer
but i think it means my good can you
look up what a deer means and then you
can decide whether i'm a deer i should
pick our spirit up so wait you you don't
have like feeling in your vagina or it's
not as much um yeah so i just noticed
this and i've been really bummed out
about it and um
the sensations have lessened it's covet
don't you think not that like you can't
taste in here and now which one of you
guys want to finger me so hard and test
me out i think i mean this is esther
would literally like
leave this earth she would pass away if
she knew that that was an offering that
she wasn't here for she wasn't here
esther is a resident lesbian
i know i like i said i've listened to
every show she's our lesson
tell us how much you love us so no i
really i really do love the show and i
was saying to kyla that like it calms me
down which i think means that there's
something wrong with me like it's
soothing to me well it's like adderall
like if you're if you don't know
it shoots you up and yeah don't it
brings you down yeah you just have um
you have like psycho
tuesday hyper
disorder
dear because of their powerful
sensitivity dear symbol for instinct and
intuition there you go there you go
annie
when the deer is your spirit guide you
have the ability to pick up on things
that others do not you're an empath i
honestly i knew that your [ __ ] was bald
before you even showed me
she didn't
i'm a [ __ ] dear i had no idea hey so
see we were talking you're right about
to tell me about the billy eilish
documentary and i stopped oh wait what
happened i don't know did you see did
you watch it no
okay what it's it's like so long ago
it's a thing of the past but we were
talking about orlando bloom
who we look like
yeah exactly yes i feel like this is so
bad to say but there's this scene in the
documentary where he comes up to her at
coachella with katie
i think it's like yeah
no it's upsetting
and he's i think he's like [ __ ] up
he's like how like hugs her multiple
times in this way that's like
really
kind of upset like she's like he's on
molly and she's yeah 17 14 whatever
and i was like
i can't this is shocking and i looked
everywhere on the internet for somebody
to say that this was creepy and nobody
has said it is that because it's orlando
bloom and like we don't talk bad about
him we don't talk bad about legolas yeah
like he's our elven brother but like is
he protected i mean honestly i would say
my friend's underage where the where
everything goes wrong is like even
though she is a musician you should not
be under 21 at a place where people are
drinking and doing drugs i think also
and it turns out she didn't even know
who he was so that's that but now she
didn't know that's the funniest thing
about it like she didn't know who he was
and then the whole thing was made into
like isn't this funny that she didn't
know who she he was and then when she
found out she wanted to go give him
another hug like nobody talked about and
i'm like of course she wants to hug a
hot older celebrity like she's 16 like
that's what is he hot in person no i
don't know
he probably he probably is super hot but
is he's little i don't know they're
always so loud is he little i don't know
if he's little you know who the littlest
hottie is is um
gael garcia oh yeah yeah oh my gosh
she's so hot oh i would put him in my
[ __ ] pocket and just keep him there
and there would be no hair at all
just slide right out
i know he's such a little and five seven
is not good he is not five seven no is
that with his foreskin or without
how tall are you guys i'm five eight
five eight and i'm five six and a half
depending on what people want
am i five six or five seven what do you
want
i'm shrinking for sure yeah i'm pretty
sure i'm not five eight anymore you're
shrinking your [ __ ] shriveling up
what's going on
[ __ ] early onset menopause no it's
not don't say that out loud
i'm a dude
oh you're not i think honestly we went
through a very traumatizing thing that
we all went through together and we're
all kind of still going through them
we've normalized it and i think a lot of
[ __ ] shut down i think a lot of
[ __ ] are on the pandemic as well
they've been sent it's a panty puss yes
i think a lot of vaginas have been um
yeah cause i think it's just like what
do you call it um
um
sensory not acclimation but it's just
like we're so used to just seeing our
partner maybe every day that we don't
get titillated
in the same way
at the brush of their skin i don't even
i look at my vibrator and i'm like all
right let's do this are you a full glass
vibrator girl yeah but i'm just like all
right
and like sometimes when it like runs out
of batteries in the middle i go like of
course you're kind of like i'm like i
totally feel you we're vibing oh wow
like it just phases but i know that i'm
gonna
i'll get will you hypnotize me back into
virility yes and i think we can i i did
do actually a
vaginal hypnosis
well you do you
dangle it in front of my [ __ ] or i
don't like when you say dangle and [ __ ]
and like
there's nothing about information it's
like you have some information you want
to be sort of oh so wait me and jenna
were talking about this how like wait
are you can you tell me how you came
into this world is it through jenna i
guess yeah through jenna yeah and then i
was on tiger belly
twice twice which is by the way to this
day the thing that people come up to me
about the most
on the street they're like i saw you on
tiger belly and i'm like
not marrying east town
maybe there's no reasons why no no
definitely not anything before mayor
beast town only i remember who you are
and 13 reasons why i haven't seen it in
so long oh i was like dressed like you
guys were on the last time oh yes okay
wait yes yes yes all right the goth
i literally look like exactly like that
look at this
[ __ ] cute you are oh my gosh that is
look at the alligator tattoos so legit
that's so funny i didn't recognize you
from that that's good costuming i don't
have tattoos in high school i i got my
first one in high school but not like
that they didn't have [ __ ] sleeves i
mean it's so funny because every single
character on the show and 13 reasons why
i had a tattoo i was like what about all
the teenagers that don't have tattoos
not like they're not allowed to feel so
left out
do you know that i can't watch picture
perfect why because i look so much like
him no because growing up because your
dad's character is somebody that i like
yeah i've never seen a young girl fap
too and i cannot i cannot i definitely
have also masturbated to your dad but in
friday the 13th when he was very young
and that was recently when he had like
this that was very recently
the knife through his uh yeah that was
the hottest
[Laughter]
i don't i've never seen either of them
i'm going to masturbate to your mom
tonight just to make it even yeah
and then me
no listen do you think i didn't watch a
thing about teen suicide with my pants
off
i'm sorry
do you think that that wasn't the type
were you excited to play that that was a
cute character to play
yeah i mean it was like the costuming
and everything so cute i was i thought i
definitely liked the fact that she was
like i mean the tattoos were like kind
of ridiculous yeah they were a lot but
it's better and they took forever and
like but i liked her her wardrobe and
stuff
i mean it was definitely fun
there's another tattoo
on any of the other
yeah i was in a relationship on the show
not in real life with
dylan the
uh
what was his name clay right yeah
on the show so yeah we made out which he
was like a lot younger than me i think i
was like i was playing a 17 year old
when i was like 25. yeah and he was
actually like 1918.
yeah
god i love that show i know i really
it's really so good
but yeah it's weird that all the k all
the teenagers had tattoos on
chest tattoos too yeah like really bold
ones like a neck tag yeah
well if you if you did like a
documentary about a high school would
they all have tattoos
now yeah no because you can't get a
tattoo well in some states you can you
need a parental you know because i got
my
mom to consent for me at 16.
to get my well i did have a [ __ ] ring
maybe that's why
oh there was nothing unpierced on my
body yeah really learning why her [ __ ]
doesn't yeah i mean
shouldn't it work better
is it do you have it is it out
like everything my tongue's out my
eyebrows out my lips out my what did it
i never got my nipples though i did you
have i saw this thing today on instagram
that was like if you
if you can get your nipples pierced you
can go through anything
i mean when i was 14.
i was
did i tell you this last time my
boyfriend told me i wouldn't be able to
handle the pain of a tattoo i was like
i've had cluster headaches nipple rings
what the [ __ ] are you talking about i
think i've been getting what's a tension
headache kalila is it the one right
there there's a strap around the back of
your head a strap-on
usually
you're getting skull [ __ ] on the back
i think it's at least my tension
headaches always start from like the my
traps here yeah and then it stressed out
and then it creeps up into my jaw and
then my head okay so that is what
attention headache i assume i get an
attention headache where people aren't
paying attention to me and i just i lose
it
i start screaming and crying
the last time we sort of got into this
um topic about um
feeling like the ick for boys we've
dated oh yeah and never turning back i
want to ask you guys what are the
pettiest reasons you've stopped liking a
boy or broken up with them it's that
feeling that comes on suddenly and then
you're like you can never go back you
know what i mean like once you once you
get the inkling of it there's no turning
back
and it could be something like so
i mean i can't remember a specific
example i remember one time i hooked up
with this guy in college
and the next day he
you know when you would hook up with
somebody in college and you woke up and
you're so [ __ ] hungover and all you
wanted to do was like get some shitty
food and like smell i'm like did i get
the grade or not
professor wake up
yeah and they were just i remember this
one guy in high school like i'm in
college stayed stayed at mike
is there something preventing you from
achieving your goals or feeling
happiness what are some mental health
barriers you overco you have to overcome
right ocd is a big one you guys should
check out betterhelp.com
trash tuesday because betterhelp will
assess your needs and match you with
your own licensed professional therapist
and you can connect in a safe and
private online environment it's so
convenient you don't have to deal with
driving parking waiting rooms all that
crap you do it all from the privacy of
your own home i also love that you could
literally do it in whatever you're
wearing you don't have to brush your
teeth before you go in like when you
need some help you could get it right
away yeah my favorite feature on this is
the journal feature so you can send a
message to your counselor anytime and
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions all without ever
having to like rick said sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room or brush your
teeth or put your makeup on you can show
up in lounge sweats and
talk your heart out
with a professional the service is
available for clients worldwide and you
can find the particular expertise that
you need online don't limit yourself to
the counselors that are just located
near you
you guys we want you to start living a
happier life today and as a listener
you'll get 10 percent off your first
month by visiting our sponsor at
betterhelp.com trash tuesday join over 1
million people who have taken charge of
their mental health again that's
betterhelp help
dot com trash tuesday we love therapy
and if you listen to this podcast you
probably need it because we're all so
[ __ ] up agreed
you know after years of fine print
contracts and getting ripped off by big
wireless providers if we've learned
anything it's that there's always a
catch right
and so when we first heard about mint
mobile which offers premium wireless
service starting at just 15
a month i thought like okay well what's
the catch but after speaking with them
and using their service it all made
sense there isn't one by cutting out
retail stores there's no crazy overhead
costs that get passed down to you in the
form of mystery fees instead mint just
passes on sweet savings direct to you
you can use your own phone with any mint
mobile plan and keep your same phone
number along with all of your existing
contacts and if you're not 100 satisfied
mint mobile has you covered with their
seven day money back guarantee switch to
mint mobile and get premium wireless
service starting at just 15 a month to
get your new wireless plan for just 15
bucks a month and get the plan shipped
to your door
for free go to mintmobile.com tuesday
that's mintmobile.com
tuesday cut your wireless bill to 15 a
month mint mobile.com
tuesday
i remember he stayed this is not really
what you're asking but i remember this
guy i hooked up with him the night
before i was so [ __ ] drunk and you
know when you want to like wake up and
be hungover and smell bad and sit in
your bed and like eat gross food and the
last thing you want to do is be around
and i remember he stayed for like
probably
20 minutes too long and he like wanted
to order food and i was like okay yeah
i'm gonna order like i have to fart
something yes that's exactly what it is
exactly there's nothing like scarf
it's got a mix in here and
it's called a swiss oven instead of a
dice
there's nothing that feels that gross
and you have to like poop a bunch of
times i mean it's just uh
hangover just the
the [ __ ] mental gymnastics to not
even accidentally fart while you're
asleep you know it's so but you
definitely do but it's like we'll just
whatever i always tell people whatever
happens when i'm asleep is your problem
it's not that's not on youtube um you
know what's so funny it's like
looking back as like a grown up you
realize you probably could have just
gone like hey can you leave exactly like
you're just like oh you think 20 minutes
is bad i once dated a cockroach
exterminator
because i thought i have a really like
visceral like a fear of cockroaches and
he was really cute i met him at mountain
bar we danced to reggae all night he was
really cute
ucla boy and i was like what do you do
as a side hustle he's like i exterminate
cockroaches i was like i'm in love
you're like squirted you're like oh my
god exterminate this didn't go home for
four [ __ ] days not from my place my
sister's house that's how many
cockroaches she had and he's like i got
so much work to do
and you know what's so crazy is because
like he was like you guys it's all about
water source
apparently you need to cut off the water
source for cockroaches to leave well
maybe that's what it is you're talking
about cockroaches on your [ __ ] and
that's why you cut off the water source
during the pandemic i hadn't spoken to
him in four years because after i told
him that his four-day stint was a little
too long
during the pentagon my friend had a
termite issue so i randomly texted him i
was like hey the last text have been
like you up
he's like yeah can i come over
before usually i didn't even say hi or
anything i was like hey like do you know
about termites and he sent me the
lengthiest thing about termites dude
this guy's so [ __ ] clutch he just
stays too long in the house and we went
to like chinese buffets with my family
like might really know who the [ __ ] he
was here's some random dude i was dating
but um he knows a lot about termites and
cockroaches so if anybody needs help
shout out
you know the guy i once uh had i once
had a guy stay
i would say
two years and eight months too long
i was supposed to be a four-monther and
three years in i was like i mean talk
about not being able to start your
boundaries i like literally couldn't
break up but this guy was like i feel
too bad he's he's a nice guy he roller
blades it's like what else does he have
oh that's the worst when you're like
people keep asking who he is it's like
he's not a rollerblader that you would
even know he'd just roll everybody and
he dated a rollerblader for a long time
meaning like a professional no like he
didn't like he it was a profession but
it wasn't but it it was a hobby it was a
passion a passion right yeah yeah i'm
crying all the time because he'd always
like break his phone
it would be so funny i'd be like
laughing so hard because i'm like you
can broken my phone
and it was three years
three years yeah three years um but i
just couldn't i could not
i wanted to sweet guy he's engaged to
congrats oh congrats yeah did she roll
her yeah i was gonna ask that does she
really no but i think she probably
respects him more than i did publicly
shaming his favorite hobby constantly i
once broke up with a guy
um in mexico while we were on vacation
because i didn't like the way he reacted
to a cockroach attack
it's very cockroach related for you it's
always it's always got to do with
cockroaches you're like if you don't
exterminate it you're not as good as my
ex exactly i need you to come with this
guy was like big and burly and he played
he was an australian guy who played um
footy is that the one part was on his
back on his shirt at the bar yeah he was
wearing a white shirt we walk into this
bar and uh um
a concord scurries under his shirt i can
see cockroaches like following you
everywhere i don't think my special
spirit guide yeah oh my god yeah why
don't you just accept them
they
can live headless for 20 days that's you
it's me
but anyways i didn't like the way so
when i saw the cockroach scurry up the
back of his imagining you'd be headed
holding your head still chilling
yeah oh somebody make that art um and so
i i saw it and instead of trying to help
him out and saying hey there's a roach
on you i'm so frightened by roaches so i
ran out of the bar and from a distance
inside of my eye i could just see the
bartender like he threw a chair on this
dude's back on on the guy that i was
dating and the guy was like so he was
hey he was doing this i didn't like it i
didn't like the way he
was like
and i was like oh no more if you can
ever
limp enough when you hit it it's like
the roach it's like art do you want me
or what would have been the correct way
for him to kill that roach on his back
but not like it's there's like a
it's too feminine it's too feminine they
have to be i will say you can go over
masculine i was dating a guy this was
like before everyone was like really
into it i dated a bjj guy a brazilian
jiu jitsu guy back in like when i lived
in santa fe
he worked at this bar willie's and i
worked at the cowgirl and we would go
bang each other in the bathrooms and he
would i would my payment was like a
prime does make me sound like a
prostitute but i would get like a pint
of jager out of it
but i was always just wasted falling i
always had like holes in my knees but
anyway so he would do the thing where
he'd be like the wasted bartender who
like if there was like a little bit of
an argument outside in the street he
would jump over the bar and like his
shirt would be and you're just like
dude yeah but it was still a little like
it was so it was it was masculine it was
like a turn off but it was also like i'm
still gonna [ __ ] you but it's hot the
first time only it's just like
if it's repetitive behavior and you have
to assert your masculinity where it
doesn't belong that's a big boner killer
it is really unattractive yeah something
like not yeah quiet i like quiet
strength exactly you don't you don't
need you don't want to like be with
somebody who's trying to prove it all
the time and if i sniff that it makes me
like he was a nice boy i do remember
when i woke up blacked out
it's funny that i drank so much in
college in those years after that i
really the guys when i go like those
guys were such good guys like they
didn't like day rape yeah oh my god like
this is enough thank you so much i know
totally but he i remember waking up on
his couch and my pants weren't button i
was like why am i he goes you unbutton
them [ __ ] i put you out there like do
not and i was like okay
but he was the guy that used to i like
had a girlfriend who looked like a boy
who was like kind of like
throwing in some vibes at me yeah for a
little while and he's the one that we
would like make out
we get drunk and make out at his bar and
he would like throw ice at us who gets
so mad why
i don't know well he always said that he
thought i was i think he was just
jealous but i think he would the way he
would say would he would go you're
leading her on and i'm like first of all
this mitchell has the reigns i promise
you
but he always thought he was like it's
not and i'm like i am like
pretty [ __ ] straight and i can't say
it but with a with enough pints of jager
yeah the tongue is wherever there's an
open wet hole
that's just gone
i'm the same way but i think that i've
retired eating [ __ ] for the rest of my
life you've i've never done anything
i've even [ __ ] yeah how did it like was
it uh threesome was it how many
different people how many likes did it
take how many different puzzles yeah um
probably maximum three okay is there a
difference between the three like was it
did you have them set up was it like all
three the last one is what did me and
that's the last one threw me into
retirement is because she didn't have
the courtesy to tell me that she had a
bv
you had a little cottage cheese for
dinner i literally just smell i could
what
wait what is it
sometimes you describe things klyla and
it's like it's so visceral
like i will never forget when you
described to me what the smell
of the poop thing that people get in the
hospital
i believe yeah yeah yeah no no no she's
talking about c diff is it yeah yes i
wouldn't i don't remember the name but
when you it's so visceral sometimes and
like the way you describe things really
makes you feel like you're experienced
but she also says it like the way she
just said it sounded like it was like a
delicious like type of kebab you could
get
it's like negative is it sediment
c diff yeah and then if you have it's
like a nosocomial infection so a lot of
people get it in the hospital and um
yeah it smells like um teen spirits toe
jam
toe jam married like the [ __ ]
like
basically honestly to point and look
upside down when you're you're trying to
select the other gross thing for today
you went you went it's like if it
married
like what disgusting thing about this
pig can i pick out
very dumb
by the way if you have bv it's all good
just saying honk the horn and say listen
don't go down on it you're like what's
bv but when you walk into a room
everyone's going who brought the fish
fillet
what's the um smell of that it's like
the most it's fishy it's extremely
efficient you can't wash it off and it
goes through all your pants and like you
you literally walk in with like a fish
cloud what
it's really bad what is it what what
causes it it's back it's a bacteria oh
bacteria
i got it from the uncuts listen uncuts
i'm a fan but you gotta just
scrub the shmeg okay take your showers
almost julian it was good sex i loved
homeless julian homeless julian i banged
he gave it to me in santa fe was it like
maybe because he was homeless that he
didn't have the he actually wasn't
homeless but he gave off a homeless vibe
okay but he did have he had a monster
truck did i tell you what i used to take
me robbing he's he would come in and hit
on me all the time at this uh bar i
worked at and i was like i can't i can't
i can't and then one day i just was like
he's like do you want to go let's go
romping in my car which is what he
called
i don't know if that's the term for it
but like taking his like monster truck
into the arroyo
and just going straight down and up and
i don't know what you call that
off-roading off-roading he caught it
romping um and we're just drunk driving
through the and then we just like drank
beers and [ __ ] on his hood and then we
went to
i think i said this because this is a
pretty monumental [ __ ] of mine because
he then put my legs behind my back so
much that it hurt and i was like dude i
haven't done yoga in a while he goes
he's like i've been trying to get you in
this position for so long if you think
i'm letting you out and i literally like
came all over him that's cool he was
really good but then the bb was great i
[ __ ] him like a couple more times he
was so dumb from concussions
i felt like he like even though he came
onto me i was like can he legally
consent at this point i was like i
wanted to like when he came to my house
i was like i want to burn the [ __ ]
sheets just in case it's evidence like
it felt like he i could see him
thinking like yeah it hurt him he'd be
like
and then this is why we ended up
breaking it off we were never like a
thing thing but i got a motor scooter a
yamaha zuma and he
like
he wanted to ride it but i was like no
i'm driving
and he like refused and so then he rode
his bicycle really fast next to mine
okay and he wouldn't do it what i love
like bmx boys yeah and it was hot and i
get that his ego was like attached to
being like the leader of a
bike yeah but i was like nah dude
dude the amount of times i've sat on uh
the handlebars of a cholo's bike i
thought you're gonna say anacholo the
amount of times i've sat on a cholo the
amount of times i've also sat on a chill
oh there is something about they're just
so
their their innate toxic masculinity is
very attractive but you know what
they're
i find them to be the least
toxic because number one cholos the
chill boyfriends i had were loyal they
were tender we listened to oldies we
listened to art label we would bike you
know bicycle around town they love
camping
like they're they're sweet and tender
loyal they're used to having to not go
to their address cops are looking for
them so they love camping
oh i love that cholo love no i do love i
mean in santa fe like there was like a
yeah it was fun do you ever date a cholo
c no
i don't think so i think i've had i've
only had like
a couple boyfriends like
like two or three oh were you raised
healthy no no no no i mean like proper
childhood no no
no no definitely not i i don't think i
didn't have i had a couple of boyfriends
in high school but i don't know if i
would like consider it that by the way
one of my boyfriends in high school
is
i found out
sorry in college
in college i found out you got confused
you're an actress i i went to brown and
there was like a major rape rapey
culture there and i found out after like
four years after high school that he had
like raped someone
that i ended up meeting and now he's
like now he's like dating someone very
much in the public eye i'll tell you
about it oh [ __ ] but nobody knows like
and i'm like
wait like somebody needs to
somebody needs he's he's not like famous
himself but he's dating somebody who's
famous and i don't know that anybody in
his like orbit knows about it but
anyways i was a real like blackout queen
in like high school college so i don't
think anybody
wanted to date me they kind of just
wanted to like
either have sex with me while i was like
a corpse or not and then like that was
my gauge of like whether or not they
were good people same thing like whether
they wanted yeah oh my god thank you you
don't want to bang me it's so nice
oh what was it like to live in santa fe
i just i can't like it seems like such a
cool place and my boyfriend loves santa
face like obsessed with it he wants to
move he not move but he wants to like
get out of town
he's from texas so i feel like that
makes sense whereas i'm from the east
coast and i'm like what what is it about
what i'm from philadelphia
which maybe i know a little bit about
you oh yeah someone from your family
might be awesome
but i
was ready to go
when i went to college i was like i'm
[ __ ] out of here and then i like the
southwest but
then i hated it right away like i ended
up leaving college and going back i went
to university or temple university for
like two weeks and then i was like i
don't like this
um and then um i went back to santa fe
and santa fe is just like
i don't know i just [ __ ] love it it's
so beautiful it's so unique i did uh
become a raging alcoholic blackout drunk
there because i was didn't have much
else to do but i'm sure it's really
beautiful we should definitely do a
[ __ ] we should go but have you been
to taos yeah that's where he's like you
have to see it i love santa fe too
because it looks like a little
old like village but it's like i don't
know it's cool i i feel like coming from
the east coast
i definitely feel
i prefer like the
west
sort of like open spaces like when i'm
back on the east coast i feel very like
boxed in by the trees i don't i don't
like
i don't know it's weird i feel like i
need like an open outdoor
plan exactly
exactly like i need to be able to see
when i was back in new york i was like i
feel like i'm it's claustrophobic even
though it's so pretty
okay you're going to be obsessed with
true bell true bill is a new app that
helps you identify and stop paying for
subscriptions that you don't need want
or simply forgot about yeah that that is
a great idea i know on average people
save up to seven hundred and twenty
dollars a year with drew bill how does
it work okay so first of all because
companies make subscriptions hard to
cancel true bill makes it incredibly
simple just link your accounts and
tribal will cancel your unwanted
subscriptions in one tap and your true
bill concierge is there when you need
them to cancel unwanted subscriptions so
you don't have to
sometimes it's hard to find how to even
cancel you go to a place and there's you
could pause it but you can't cancel they
do that on purpose it's crazy it's
really that cancel button is so hard to
find and it's intentional it's the
clitoris of the marketing world okay
don't fall for subscription scam start
canceling today at truebill.com trash
tuesday go right now truebill.com
trash tuesday it could save you
thousands a year this is a huge deal we
love trueville truebill.com trash
tuesday do you feel like you have a
cabinet full of acne treatments and
you're confused and you like don't know
which one to use and like there's so
much skin care out there you don't know
what you're lost basically look when i
first started getting melasma do you
know what that is rick
i don't
melasma is discoloration in the upper
lip and it tends to be a very finicky
thing to get solved right
which is why i love apostrophe because
it was a dermatologist that i could
speak to immediately
who basically said you're using all the
wrong things and this is what you need
yeah i just feel like there's so many
products out there that i don't know
what to do and i need like clear
direction and apostrophe is a
prescription skincare company that
offers science-backed oral and topical
medications that are clinically proven
to help clear acne and apostrophe
connects you with a board-certified
dermatologist who will create a
personalized treatment plan that is
perfectly tailored to your unique skin
simply fill out apostrophe's online quiz
about your skin goals medical history
and then snap a few selfies and your
dermatologist will create your
customized treatment plan
and i like it because they work on all
you know it's a dermatologist they work
on all your skincare goals so for me
like i have spots i want to get rid of
i have really dry skin i'm always
looking to reduce redness obviously
anti-aging is the thing so
it's like what are your skincare goals
let them know and they can really help
you for instance like i didn't know like
i just oh this is eczema on my skin or
this is dermatitis but they're able to
say no this is what type of dermatitis
that is
um you should not be using this uh skin
thinning steroid on that part of your
body very specific things yeah and it's
nice to know that your products have
come from a real dermatologist and
they're tailored for you we have a
special deal for our audience you can
save 15 off your first visit with a
board certified dermatologist at
apostrophe.com
tuesday when you use our code tuesday
this code is only available to our
listeners to get started just go to
apostrophe.com tuesday and click begin
visit then use our code tuesday at sign
up and you'll get 15 off your first
dermatology visit that's
a-p-o-s-t-r-o-p-h-e dot com tuesday news
code tuesday to get your dermatology
visit and save 15 and we thank
apostrophe for sponsoring this podcast
can you put the ac down a little though
[ __ ] are you hot or cold no she
wants my nipples to show oh no it turned
down yeah
i told you when i went home and my
sister-in-law was so worried she thought
it was cold in her house because my
nipples were hard
oh yeah that's right my shirts are so
graphic around my nephews
but didn't you say on the podcast that
you have like forever hardness yeah
because of the piercings wow kinda i
mean they're not that's cool because i
don't like like looking at my boobs when
they're done doesn't this look good
so good i saw you you drew them in but
you guys i had to go to tender greens to
get food before this like this
it looks good it's fine what is la do
you think anybody had a different a
second cut a little bit nobody would
even i have gotten recognized from this
podcast at that tender grounds too i was
like where's my free remember when i got
a free okay
i guess i'm paying for this
wait so what were you saying sorry
mushrooms and towels i went to yeah i
went to um with my friends in santa fe
her someone had given me just like
random shake of mushrooms and we put
them on a quesadilla thinking nothing
would happen and we got so we were
tripping so hard at this [ __ ]
bar
and um my friends it was really crazy we
were it was insane to be around
someone's mother while this was all
happening
and uh so then my friend had this
chrysler baron and we drove
it to where the [ __ ] did she live but we
drove out into the desert where her like
aunt lived in like it was one of those
houses where like her aunt and uncle
like
bought a plot and then built their dream
home so it was like we were going to
like literally the [ __ ] coolest it's
so cool and we drove out and a pink
floyd block came on the radio and we
were i just remember going this is the
best moment in my life and honestly
there's been a lot of best moments but
that is still in there
what i want to do is i want to i want to
know what it's like to
be in the ocean on mushrooms yeah like
actually dive
you should get a [ __ ] like legit
shaman like when you go to hawaii i bet
you there's like a sick legit shaman
that can like do a whole water ceremony
thing with you like
it's good like because i feel like we do
these all recreationally but if you can
have someone that's like a guide that
can really you can it can be so like did
you guys not hear bobby has offered me
to a hawaiian god
i like that you're touching your massive
ears no he literally has did you guys
not hear come on guys where where's your
intuition annie he's already offered me
up to hawaii where's the deer i never
literally said i could have sex with him
oh it was a specific man is a specific
man oh i thought he just said you can
[ __ ] whoever you want no
is this specific
i can't [ __ ] whoever i am like he had a
sexual reaction to a man and was like
i think
you can or can't [ __ ] whoever i can and
should is what he said what really but
to a specific person
oh so it's just one i thought he said he
just opened you up i was like this is
not good no no no no he didn't open me
up oh to one guy okay this is the
cupcakes the cupcakes yeah yeah yeah
what cupcakes cupcakes it was last week
we had uh maddie matheson on and he
we were talking about
jizz on
cox we were talking about cucks
basically and like i think that is
i'm a little bit of a [ __ ] where it does
turn me on if i think about my partner
kind of i like when i see people hit on
my boyfriend like i'm like talking to
you drive uber or something you need to
get out there more like
i gotta see some girls gripping you up
yeah like if somebody else thinks your
boyfriend's hot or like yeah yeah i
think if you're like secure in your
relationship you know that you're
getting a bonus yeah yeah yeah yeah and
i like to sit in the corner and watch it
happen like when like after bobby shows
when i see like women like hey like
these look at these nipple tassels and
i'm just sitting there and i don't i
don't i don't go find my nipple tassels
i don't i don't interrupt it i just sit
and i watch like you probably like
you're watching it too maybe
i i don't know i just like it i like
watching it yeah it's i well because we
know i go that isn't good oh yeah you
should want that
yeah exactly because you know that you
like won it's kind of [ __ ] up yeah
sometimes it's like good to remember
that you're right yeah i mean like i my
instinct is that this is like a super
hot awesome person that
you want to [ __ ] jump their bones and
then when you see someone else do it you
go like that's right i wasn't blinded
right right yeah it's more universal not
that you need everyone else to think
that but yeah no i mean i no i totally
get that you're like oh yeah no he is
amazing
insecurity in a relationship if you
really are like
get the [ __ ] away from my boyfriend it's
like why like what
are you that like do you find it that
and also for guys like if they get super
jealous it's like dude oh that's a big
boner killer it's a turn off it means
that you're not
i'm on my high horse like with this yes
it means every time we say listen
yeah i think it means that you're
insecure in our relationship which i
think makes me feel like trapped yeah
that's why i don't i wouldn't want to do
it to another person but also it's to
not trust me means you're not
trustworthy in my head right like people
are projecting the things like when
people assume i'm lying about something
i'm like why would you i never assume
people are lying yeah i never go there
unless i've like learned through their
actions before that that's something
they do but i never i always assume
people are telling the truth because i'm
like
it shall set you free no i'm like why is
george putting up a banana like that oh
it's banana bread okay but it is weird
still what he did it
the way that you were holding it was so
interesting
[Music]
i felt that way um during mayor of east
town the bathtub scene
with the baby oh i was like saucy i know
josie
wake up
like literally that's when the baby was
oh yeah that was like such a traumatic
scene a show in general the show was
very traumatic so good to watch being
something that makes us happy i know
right like so and i'm about to do this
really dark oh wait
i have a show that's not depressing
it should be out in january notice how
you didn't remember it for a second
you sick [ __ ] i know right like can i
get a comedy i mean i'm not i know i'm
not funny but like
oh my god that's so sad you've been
being funny the whole time [ __ ] love
yourself
no but like
how to come anybody has been funny
no but i mean like i don't i think i'm a
pretty light person so the fact that i'm
in all these
traumatic shows i'm like this is why
you're a good actress yeah it's
depressing
i am on a show that isn't dark but then
i'm about to do this movie that's like a
horror movie
about
like it's so it's so [ __ ] dark and
every single frame is like just dark and
depressing and i'm like not again
the only problem with that is that
i find in horror movies when the acting
is actually good it's really really
distracting it's like you really need it
to be bad sometimes and um to take you
out of it guys when the rapes i'm like
these rape scenes are literally
i'm ptsd twitching watching these i need
someone to be bad at this i need someone
to like look into this straight into the
game
no i'll wake up and my boyfriend loves
her so i'll just wake up to [ __ ] that's
like so crazy as long as it's not true
murder i'm good mm-hmm
we have so many true murderous shows on
it's i can't like i used to be really
into it
and i i just cannot it's not good yeah i
think that i was i had a phase as well
but i realized it was also seeping into
my mental health because my road trips i
would just be like sweating buckets yeah
no it is very like it really does bring
you down and it's dark and that's why i
started like watching
like have you guys seen a hundred foot
wave yeah see that shit's like you know
what really pissed me off about that
documentary when he was like and when
they're like it's coping
it's like literally this big massive up
and then it was like the wife like like
me like stirring she's always cooking
okay yeah she's always talking
what is it
the whole time i get it the wife like
okay but like i was just like this poor
lady she's on the [ __ ] lighthouse
calling telling you where the waves are
i'm like and then she's like always
cooking i'm like can you stop showing
like something and holding a baby and
i'm like chasing a really big weight
so he goes through
portugal and what really pissed me off
about that he
he was like he told his wife to surf one
of the bigger the bigger sets that they
do and she washed up on shore she
couldn't breathe she was she she
has such a bad ptsd that she can't even
surf small waves and then he went out
and kept surfing yeah by the way i would
[ __ ] kill my husband if they told me
to [ __ ] go out and surf one of the
biggest waves and i was like okay and
then i almost died yeah i would be so
[ __ ] angry and there's footage of her
just passed out on the [ __ ] sand
would you wouldn't you be angry you also
have to probably see it from his side
where it's like you know when someone is
just so impassioned about one thing and
they fixate on that one thing and they
have to conquer it i imagine that's
really just all he dreams about all
night for sure it's like she can't take
that away from him but also he can't
make her surf those waves yeah like he
probably just wanted her to like
have the experience because this is what
bobby did what it is what bobby did to
me it's just like here you should do
stand up you should do stand up and
guess what i did i had a [ __ ] heart
attack on stage well some people some
people like have a different temperament
it's like it's it is weird to think that
everyone would want and that's why i
have to remember like even when i'm
talking about this like true crime stuff
it's like well i just have my opinions
like do your thing but it's like it's
like other people have their thing that
they want to do like there's no like
right or wrong right yeah so i love
doing stand-up but i completely
understand how that is like not a thing
you want to do
i like
doing like when we're talking to matty
and he's like completely sober like i
don't drink but i don't know but i don't
say i don't think like everyone you
gotta go do this or whatever yeah
i will say when i get covered tested i'm
always like are you gonna find special
am i gonna get diagnosed with special
okay
oh you got up there wait so see you and
i have this in common we love the trashy
reality love shows wow oh yeah i can i
can go so far remember when i was in new
york and then i think you were in new
york but we were there for two separate
things and we were going back and forth
about dean from the bachelor oh my god
what about an idea baby
babies what about you
oh my gosh
this is so funny i talk to these people
don't worry i'm involved in these words
wait you do you know him i've never
spoken to him but there's
survival so before
oh yeah [ __ ] love survivor i like
them all i mean i like like real world i
saw jamae from the real world in new
orleans and like took a picture with her
i like totally geeked out she was like
wow challenge of course i'm so i talked
to all of them
johnny bananas is really avoiding me i
don't know why johnny i bought your i
bought a picture and then starstruck i
signed a picture of johnny bananas when
he took the money from sarah and he
chose to not give her the money i bought
a signed picture johnny like
wes told you everyone's told i love what
jordan has told you we love us west
knows wes looks at my like
i'll see that he's looked at my stories
and then i'll scream and i'll send it to
him like wes this means a lot
i just want you to know every time
jordan um
i think he used to be with joanna right
yeah but that was so long ago yeah he's
married and
i can totally see you guys being on the
challenge
i could i will have the personalities
like and the like the look i just don't
have the alcoholism do you know jordan
jordan that's true you didn't watch
since jordan well i don't a lot of them
are [ __ ] sober this one you know
jordan the one that has one hand
he came to yeah
shows he came in my shows and uh
in burbank i got all these pictures with
them yeah
they all live in l.a don't they i i want
to know what you dmd baby okay so it was
before i knew that he had come back to
bathroom paradise this is before he got
with kalyn yes yeah but obviously they
were together in real life it's just
that oh was that those we didn't know it
yet yeah you know how no they had kept
it secret you know what i mean like and
you didn't know whether or not they
stayed together or whatever and i so i
was at this is so [ __ ] embarrassing
i'd i
had just like recently gotten out of
like a five-year relationship so i was
just being like wild
so every so just everywhere you stood
was bachelor in paradise
exactly like in my head but i didn't my
group of friends is like 10 people like
there was no option so i was like okay
so anyways i was at my
i was somewhere and i was like i know
when i was in my relationship i didn't
drink like i was sober full on and then
when we broke up i started like
reintroducing alcohol into my life i
didn't know he's not drunk and that's
why he didn't trust yeah basically i
would say i mean i started drinking like
a year before we broke up absolutely no
no he knew but it was very much like one
drink or two drinks oh my god was he
jealous was he like you can just drink
one or two drinks [ __ ] he was just
weird about other about
other people maybe he's not anymore but
like i feel like
he didn't want he didn't like being
around other people that were [ __ ] up
that was like a very big thing for him i
like seeing that because it reminds me
bobby does too
nothing turns him on more than when i
come home
drunk out of my mind oh really like too
bad for him though it happens like once
every time like rarely yeah i don't ever
really get drunk and i was very much not
gonna get drunk when i was with him
because he like did not like it so i was
like okay okay i won't do it and then
just you know we broke up so i was like
i'm free like you know whatever so
anyways i think i was like tipsy
we were at my house and i was with my
friends and i was like i'm gonna i'm
gonna
um
dm dean
okay so we're all sitting around trying
to figure it out like saying i i told
everyone that he lived in a fan like it
was at a time that we were and so my
friend michael took my my phone and just
dm'd him
i know some good spots in la with no
street cleaning
so you can like park your van there cute
yeah i was like this is perfect like boy
come on i had like the blue check i was
like there's no [ __ ] way he's not
gonna respond like
no response a week later it comes out
that he went back for kaelin now they
live together in the goddamn van they
are a really cute couple though and we
did we did stand them so see to be fair
we just didn't know they were getting
back together i just didn't realize that
bodes well for dean that like he was in
a relationship with caitlyn and like he
didn't respond to a deep deal yes you
know i'm like that's awesome
just kidding
i'm trying to think of celebrities i've
dm'd
that i never got a response back from
but then i've only ever dm'd one person
one celebrity in my whole life and he
did reply and that's doug stanhope oh
when i was living alone in long beach
he's like my favorite comic of all time
i'm supposed to go to the desert with
him i know i know that he doesn't i
cancelled a weekend doug but when i was
in my 20s i was just obsessed with him
and he was going to do a show at the
alex bar in long beach was like a really
small dive bar and i was like oh this is
so like his his brand of course he would
do a show here at alex bar who does a
[ __ ] show at alex bar
and um i wrote him i was like hey you
know really innocently i think i might
have been like 23.
oh my god you're right down the street
from me he was like great bring bring
the drugs
that's all he ever replied with and i
was like oh he's obsessed he's the best
i um
met zach galifianakis at the snake pit
the bar on i think it's on sunset
when i was like 21
and he wasn't like famous famous like i
think he'd been in what was an apple
music video he'd been in the fiona apple
music video great music what was the
snowboarding movie he was in
there was some snowboarding movie
and he had and he had done
i think there was he had a his special
live at the purple onion
was out and i said something there was
some joke i was like oh i liked your
joke about like [ __ ] your cousin or
something and he's like oh i don't this
was way before i did comedy
and um he's like i don't have that joke
which i do believe he did have a joke
then he was just maybe trolling me or
whatever but i remember he gave me his
number
and then i um called him
he just left him a message and i was
like hey it's annie from the snake pit
and he never called me back but it was
like it was a positive good interaction
was it before so it was like you didn't
dm you called you actually got his
number yeah i flipped my phone open yeah
besides remember those envy phones that
you go ch and they went oh yeah i never
had one i never had a sidekick yeah it
was like a sidekick i remember the
sidekick yeah yeah
it was like a lame sidekick oh
so see have you ever heard so seriously
no not like that it's just i remember
the sidekicks had an easier flip and
then like the envy
speaking of envy
you have a little envy for the uh
sidekick huh and for k i wonder if kayla
kaelin probably had a sidekick she
probably for sure
also have you ever shot your shot with
anyone besides beanie babies no no i've
never dm just like i said i feel like
after when i turned 20
one i was just in relationships so i
knew that was the first time that i had
been single and i was single for like
two weeks
so it's not like it's wasted i had a lot
of time getting tipsy
i um
aggressively tried to get to manifest um
leave schreiber inside of me and
i even told my agent i go just get me to
the ray donovan party and i'll do the
rest oh yeah and then as time went on i
it went away
i don't want anything to crush i don't
want i don't i don't ever
i've never met an actress been impressed
um i've never thought that
no but i've never like my crushes are
never they're always on a character yeah
and then you see the person you go oh
you're an actor okay i'm a psycho
yeah i think it's because actors like
definitely a lot of them
um
are very insecure and i think it's like
very easily sniff right when you meet
them you know i mean they wear their
insecurity like
right on yeah
right out there so either they're like
trying to prove that they're
something that they're not or you know
what i mean i mean i'm dating an actor
and my everyone in my family is an actor
so i it sounds like i'm i don't know
it's [ __ ] on your health
was your dad
did you feel like did you
did you miss your dad when he was
filming the invisible man
were you like more like the invisible
dad
i saw that with my dad
can i take these out what was it called
man what was it hollow man
[ __ ] no it's fine hollow down hollow did
it like goes down except
i don't even we were all there except
him you know what i mean so she asked if
we had any snacks today and we do today
why do we have to eat like groceries i
feel like we're just repeating at this
point i feel like i've eaten these
before
what are these
this is earthworm jerky every time i eat
one of these i feel like kalila's vagina
nothing i've never tried this is it good
let's hypnotize i'll find some hypnosis
for i'll ask my hypnotist if we can do
this one
mind-blowing orgasm well you said can
you just like smoke out the demons out
of my [ __ ]
i think there are demons in there let's
do let's do demons angry horned demons
what is this
oh we got bug this tastes like the
flavor of the jerky not the yeah
earthworms i'm
i think they put too much stuff on it
like garlic and okay here we have a
kebab and i'll tell you okay they look
like um um worms and crickets oh my god
there's a cricket face oh it's okay face
i want to eat a face oh great okay grass
smoke worms
and salt there you go it's going to
taste like salt it's actually tastier
than all the others oh my god this one
had to pass
what is that
that's a lot this one's not as bad annie
better than all the previous ones i do
see the eyes do you think that would you
like on the challenge because we could
eat like gross stuff do you eat anything
do i eat anything what do you mean i
mean like what are your limits with food
i don't have me neither any like limits
or allergies or anything those are good
yeah they're not bad right
you've changed you changed yesterday
all the fans let let esther know you
miss her in the comments i think this
would have been more fun with esther
here i'm sorry i'm sorry the one part
i know i'm sorry i'm not freaking out
enough
at the i'm so like i mean we're gonna
have to really start up in this because
i'm really getting like very immune to
bored
what you got pete
if you [ __ ] bring a cockroach
in here though everyone is done that's
the only thing we can do oh you i do i
[ __ ] dare you oh my god patreon can
you eat i'm gonna keep this for later
because the whole bag worm drinking just
tastes like jerky flavor you know what
you mean like it's not that's what i
call flavor
or it's like a the taste of like
something that's been in a bag for yeah
yeah
shelf life taste yeah wait do you have
like um dietary restrictions like
of like gluten or yeah
we don't
i get a rash on my legs with gluten but
i just don't
go right through it i know you push
right through it it's just annoying it's
like i i mean i would like to maybe
start listening to my body more yeah
and yeah daily diarrhea probably isn't
good but i
i chronically [ __ ] blood and i just
power through life because i'm unwilling
to give up the food that i like i know
i'm like anything is well i remember
going to get like um my mom took me to a
homeopath doctor
and they did the thing where that you
like hold like a jar with and it says
eggs in it and you push down which i'm
i'm always like are you gonna hit by the
hour i'm so confused
but i mean i guess it's wrong yeah
muscle testing but i'm always like
didn't i just okay you're pushing
oh wait can i tell you the reason why i
broke up with a guy yeah
in seventh grade david romberg i'm
saying full names here he knows what i'm
talking about showed up he was in eighth
grade we were boyfriend and girlfriend
for a couple weeks he was an art his dad
was an artist who's from argentina he's
cool dave's cool still cool
he showed up in leather pants and i was
like goodbye we're too young to take
fashion risks like this i was so
humiliated i couldn't believe it i was
so mortified that's
embarrassing and it was and we were done
oh my gosh do you know that one time oh
this was actually in high school okay
high school not college i know you said
that are you sure
i swear this was really in high school
because i remember i called my high
school best friend
i called my best friend and i was like
i think i was hooking up with this was
that hannah or she was dead
can you imagine you having a real high
school life
i had just gotten my alligator neck hat
and
now
i went over to
this guy that i was hooking up with his
house and we like made out and i
called my friend and i was like
normally when i really like someone like
i don't i won't have to poop around them
for a really long time
and i had to poop i was over there do
you think that means that i don't like
him that's so [ __ ] up that's obviously
my problem
i was like blaming it on literally
anything but the fact that i just
obviously didn't like him you mean i was
like this is a sign
it was your body telling you
listen i want to take a dump in front of
this guy that's how much i don't want to
fight yes that's what in my head that's
the way i sort of like rationalize it
and i didn't really like him it's like
that obviously was true but i was like i
called my best friend and she was like
so see that's so messed up sociopathic
yeah
you worry
i feel i
look here's my thing about feeling the
ick the it comes within two week window
yeah getting first getting with you is
that a small deal
yes
hard to feel sometimes it's suctioning
but
i do you know what small you've been a
micropenis right of course yeah i was in
love i was in love and love with a guy
with micro penis so
we're not a shout out
and we are hoping
the love is fading
you guys aren't in love with him
um but yeah it's in the first two week
window where you're first hooking up
with someone that just about anything
can kind of like turn you off but the
truth is it's your
intuition being like this isn't like
there's so much going on when you're
first dating someone right it's like you
have like the pheromone match or not yes
you have like the excitement of
something new and honestly like i was
attached and i think just because of
like
the way the chaos in my household when i
was a kid it's like
just
i liked
the idea that someone wasn't going to
like me but i don't know it was like
really sick so i was like it's the
unknowing that's exciting yeah but then
when you realized you like had them
you're like yeah when you have to poop
in front of them for the first
what a sad time day that is just
but yeah you know definitely it's not
this will not last a lot of the two is
not necessarily your ic against that
person it's your ick
of yourself yeah with that person
reflecting on reflecting because my
friend she was dating a b-boy and the
first night that they slept together
they were spooning and she farted on his
dick b-boy like a break dancer oh yeah
and they were spooning and she farted on
his date it's hard because he was
spinning her
it's hard to hold in a fart and she was
so ashamed of herself that like she just
ended it completely like the next yeah
totally it could be about your own it
could be about your own behavior around
them and you're like ew i'm so gross
with this person i fart on todd's dick
like it's an alarm in the morning for
him to get up i'm like i can't wait i
flip onto his dick
if i'm away from him i'm like wake up
sunshine
and i will say tonight we get very happy
we wake up
extremely happy i bring randy up to get
in the clouds that's so cute
yes that's really cute you guys thank
you so much this has been
trash tuesday and it was an absolute
[ __ ] delight what thank you for
having me you have to come back so i
will you want to know what we were going
to dress as what eggs
so you'd be the baby
it might just be can you imagine if we
just didn't like like invisible man
oh my god we just didn't show up
we just didn't
[Applause]
by the way if you want to join us um we
are all i don't know if you saw the
movie conair if you've seen it
also
well you're uninvited to our halloween
party because we forgive you we don't
like you anymore but we forgive you
didn't watch last season
i know i know wow no it's just exciting
is it a good one everything's good it's
always good
but this season's good too i mean
they're always good
well thank you guys so much for watching
we'll see you next week a guy got a
concussion and his and his penis flopped
out
[Music]
in right now no but your hair is not i
do have nice hair yeah i just can't eat
it yeah you should clip it into your
pubes
one on the one you have left you just
it might damage the last follicle